boy only works on one type of girl
really only one type of
girl oh I'll hear her out hold on and
those girlies are words of affirmation
girli no you're dating out of your
league sis that's what that means the
women today I see so many that are
frustrated because all of a sudden the
good God they oh she got the last good
guy there are a million good guys out
there but it doesn't feel like it I know
feel like there's a lot more good women
than men in my
opin oh no it's so funny the narcissism
standards I could pick a guy that is
good enough like will do and will be
obsessed with you sure but I don't want
that out of my league what up guys
welcome to the just cly things YouTube
channel and welcome to my reaction
series today I'm going to be reacting to
whoops this strong independent woman
can't afford her luxury lifestyle
anymore as you guys know a lot of women
are going to be unemployed because of AI
a lot of women have useless jobs in the
market and AI is going to replace it
starting with only fans but before I
start make sure you get a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt as you guys
already know women I mean we look look
at what's happened since we got the
right to vote get yourself a T-shirt and
make sure you tweeted me your pictures
of you in your t-shirts being an
independent woman is just like so
exciting until something happens and you
could really use someone who's extra
strong and extra tall okay I am painting
my bathroom okay but I have to wait like
30 minutes in between each coat so I was
like you know what I'm going to go make
dinner while I do that but then I was
like you know what I have to clean the
dishes in the sink put them to dry so I
had them drying and then I was like I'm
going to put them up like where they
belong okay then I had my little utensil
thing this thing sitting right there and
the stove was over there had it sitting
right there I go to put the scissors in
okay except somehow and all the halalu
it went right behind the stove so I just
had to like pull this stove stove out
from the wall okay and you have to lift
it up to pull it cuz there's like a
ledge and then it's disgusting back
there and they dropped all the way to
the bottom and like I am not tall enough
or Nimble enough to somehow get down
there so I was like brilliant idea I'll
use kitchen tongs cuz I'm already going
to have to like bleach anyway but I
still with these my arms not long enough
to get over there and also I have like a
pretty tall sink area and so I was like
I don't know if I can climb on top of
there and like somehow lay down to get
all the way down so I end up basically
planking on that much counter and I
somehow get the scissors out with this
but then I see this and like I've
already wash it like four times I was
like well then I have to clean that cuz
like that's absolutely dis so now I'm
cleaning that on both sides waiting for
the 30 minutes to be up cuz I was like
well I got to wait till the next 30
minutes to cook my dinner now because of
all this H blue and I can't get the
stove back in like it's just jutting out
into the kitchen like I try pushing and
the door of the oven
concave there's so many little things
that we take for granted that men do for
us most women women have no idea how
much the men in their lives do for them
and we take it for granted every single
day and a lot of times women give up a
good thing because they don't know what
they have until it's
gone if you are wondering why you can't
find a good man I just want you to
listen to these questions and see if
this matches up with you okay one you
are always following boys two your love
language is words of affirmation three
you can't really stay in a relationship
that long or you're in situationships a
lot that just end up with you having
your heart broken if any of those are
you let me tell you why this keeps
happening boy only works on one type of
girl really only one type of girl I'll
I'll hear her out hold on and those
girlies are words of affirmation
[Music]
girly no you're dating out of your
league sis that's what that means so if
you like someone telling you all of the
wonderful things about you oh I'm I'm
going to do all this stuff but then they
never it's always the men that know how
to sell dreams I mean obviously it's the
men with the experience that's what they
got to do really do what they they're
just you know it's it's women shooting
too high they're going to or they just
like don't really want to hang out or
they don't text you back that's boy and
buck boys love to talk and you my girly
pop love to listen this is the thing me
personally My love language is not words
of affirmation it is giftgiving and acts
of service I'm just hoping the women
today I see so many that are frustrated
because all of a sudden the good guy
they say oh she got the last good guy
there are a million good guys out there
but it doesn't feel like it I know it
feels like there's a lot more good women
than men in my so funny the narcissism
the absolute narcissism it's the men not
me the the girls that that zoom in
quickly
and they do zoom in they see there's a
good guy walking down the street they're
going to grab him yeah you know the ones
you're going oh maybe I don't like the
way he's got his hair combs his shoes
look terrible those girls don't think of
that they see this guy they see that
he's going to be make a good living he's
sort of cute he'll be fine he'll be fine
well it depends I guess how particular
you are because if you are a particular
person yeah see it's like the women of
the past telling these chicks too picky
I think you're ever going to get around
to being the one who's like oh they'll
do like I you're like that you're and
that's great but but I am I'm a n an
overthinker and I think that would be
very difficult for me yeah it almost
feels like the conversation to be
perfect are you perfect no nobody's
perfect settling versus like having what
is settling what is settling I mean by
this logic it's like you can't settle
for something you don't qualify for what
is settling standards I could pick a guy
that is good enough like we'll do and
we'll be obsessed with you sure but I
don't want that I want to pick someone
that oh my God out of my league
goodbye I'm going to be out a walker by
by the time the two of you make a
commitment even I think women are more
commitment phobic than men nowadays the
face of an older lady saying this is
what women do when they want to be kept
you're wondering why you can't have a
good man or can't find one there's
plenty of them you just focus on the
wrong things this is what you need to be
focusing on even in the face of that
rather respectfully they say oh well I
don't want to settle you don't want to
settle for being taken care of being
taken out on dates getting that princess
treatment that you're talking about
because he doesn't look the greatest
news flash some of these women out here
don't look the I don't really believe in
the whole princess treatment I say life
is hard it's time to help CH but they're
married why do you think that is it's
not settling it's she's cute to me and I
think in tandem with these other
qualities she is wifey material but
Society has programmed you to think that
you're settling for a man that has a
good job but maybe his shoes don't look
the greatest you could literally just
say you know bab we got some money in
the bank we go get you some other shoes
oh you know maybe you could change that
shirt well why don't you get this
hairstyle you know Simple Solutions that
you as a modern woman cut relationship
all four you got to stop well I'm fine
being single and lonely you're going to
have to be because you've put yourself
in this position well I'm fine been hit
in the face you're going to have to be
you've been talking trash if you're a
bully and you go up and you're messing
with someone people are going to say you
had it coming to you am I condoning
violence absolutely not I'm just giving
you an example of how modern women think
today and then when the result Happ well
I'm fine with that news flash it was
always going to happen it was just a
matter of time that's what the wall is
it's not to disrespect you but it's only
a matter of time until your attitude and
your ego and your pride runs up against
a wall and you're going to have nothing
to show for it and you're going to yeah
because at a certain point your
character is supposed to take you
through the rest of your life but you
know and it was kind of known like the
older women would know at some point
Beauty Fades and it's important to have
family community character but now it is
me me me my feelings me me me me me and
you're going to need therapy be careful
he can decide who's going to work and
who's not going to work so he's chosen
the black woman to work but we think we
have Ave somehow we have Miss women
women choose to work we we make our bad
interpreted that we think because we got
the jobs and we the money we all that
it's a false sense of power and we
Straten out our power around in front of
our men making them pull back from us
and we wondering why our men are
crossing over Chinese white woman
anything that shows femininity black
women don't know that we're just being
completely torn apart and broken down so
we will not have no appeal to this man
he doesn't want to everyone says that
I'm still single because my standards
are too high so here's a list of small
gestures that make me really happy
so on list number one is buying me a
house this is just a little quick PS
buying you a
house
what you guys are getting houses want to
be i n d e p e n d e n t if you know
what that means like I lose weight we
have a husband to be dealing with these
car then lose weight why do I have to
deal with them because you didn't lose
weight air my back tire and I don't want
to do it another man in the bedroom with
him in it's Ro reversal so now you're
working hard you start feeling like a
man and when you start feeling like a
man all of a sudden you don't need this
man that God gave you you roll reverse
and you go get a Woman They seated you
for you never chose it they have been
grooming you for over 400 years so that
when you finally make a choice you will
choose to be the man so have never
worked on me now my
friends doubt it always get caught up
with the boy why friends right okay that
I did some analysis and found out
there's a
correlation you are succumbing to these
words these men are saying because words
are
easy true Bo like to make it as easy as
possible with as limited work as
possible they love it they eat it up as
simple as they can so they'll romance
you they'll say all the things you want
to hear but then they won't follow
through ever so my tip of advice my tip
of advice my advice for you I guess if
you are a words of affirmation girly
please be conscientious of their actions
and their words combined don't just
listen to The Things They say really
look closely at the things they do this
is going to save you so much heartbreak
and dads used to do this there's a
reason that they kept us away from you
know they'd be like stay away from that
boy and the woman would be like no I
love him and the dad would be like get
him out of here there's a reason there's
a reason and and you know in all the
movies it's like ah my evil dad but
they're just looking out for you so so
much time by just analyzing them before
jumping in that's saying that she's
happy to Independent ly I don't want to
be in independent era I don't give a
about that who [__] is happy to pay
bills by theirself
H nobody I would rather chew
dirt I would rather chew I mean that's
just kind of part of being an adult I'm
not with this I have a nuanced view on
women working I have a nuanced view um I
think women should stay home with the
children yes but I think before you have
kids and after your kids are older older
I mean it's not about being useless like
you could do something I I know like
80-year-old grandmas I mean honestly
they can do they they work around the
farm it's like they have more energy
than the 20-some year olds and now we
just have a generation of like useless
women that just want like this princess
treatment no thank you and that's where
I'll leave it today quite honestly this
is the attitude that all strong and
independent women should have and you
know what I'll make an amendment to that
statement because there's some women out
there that are strong and independent
but they've gone through some
mishandlings so it's harder for them to
trust I'll leave space for that but for
the vast majority of strong and
independent women who have been taught
by Society to be this way will choose
being strong and independent over
chewing dirt but they're never they're
never in strong and independent they're
always getting their money from a man
alone or debt chewing dirt could be I
mean occasionally there's like one or
two but to being usually their viewers
are male oh well low being humble and
I'm not saying that if your man asks you
to kiss his feet or chew dirt that you
should do that my only thing is your
attitude how do you treat him are you
too highminded do you think that he and
everyone else around you they are not
good enough they can never match me they
can never equal me and because they
can't then they'll never be good enough
for me girl you ain't doing nothing that
ain't been done before you ain't making
no money breaking no barriers that ain't
been done before I'm not saying that
you're not unique I'm just saying how
you think I will I'll say that here
ain't really it it's actually
interesting when you start looking at
history and you realize nobody's really
that unique like they had crazy ladies
all throughout time even there's
writings from the 1800s of men saying
that women's standards were too
high you know I mean this isn't new it's
not new you getting your bag and
bringing in clients but bro you really
think most dudes going to overlook that
attitude that you got just because you
got a man yeah like women think that
looks can override their character but
it only works for so long and a Ferrari
and you pulling in about 600k a year
they going to want to wife you hey yo
give me an allowance they're not wiing
anybody like you think Drake's ever
going to have a real wife 200 you can
say whatever you want to say I'm being
factious but I think you get it it's
it's time for you guys to come up out of
the clouds and hopefully find a guy but
that's just my opinion until the next
video Yeah and this is the thing again
most strong independent women women are
in debt they not really making money
like that they maybe work in retail and
have some side gig on Instagram where
they don't make money maybe they're on
off or maybe they have a human resources
job they're not really independent like
that but let me know what you guys think
in the comments make sure you like the
video on your way out subscribe and get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
in the description I'll talk to you next
time